okay so this is very best functions we
give there's one more thing we need to
say because I teased it yesterday which
is uh what was the last function we
looked at yesterday we looked we looked
at x-squared and what we concluded was
this what what eraser was uh what we
conclude it was is that x squared has
the inverse function y doesn't have any
best function okay so when we do we go
back to the geometry of it right I don't
know if you end up trying this but if
you didn't please do it now when you
take the original function and you carry
out its reflection right what you're
getting we did say this I remember like
yesterday is you get plus or minus so
you get these two brushes right and that
graph that I've got their blue fails the
vertical line test so it's not a
function
it's a relation so this is an inverse
relation that I'm looking at right here
I really shouldn't call it f because
it's I'm gonna call this plus or minus
the square root of x okay not a function
however I want to function I want a
function right so being that this fails
the vertical line test and I've switched
X of Y right
what does the vertical line test look
like for the original function and the
answer is it's not vertical anymore it
will be because I switched right it'll
be horizontal okay
so I can say because this guy fails the
horizontal line test that is why this is
not a function okay
this failing the horizontal line test
will make this fail the vertical line
test okay so I might just say this fails
this fails okay so what we must do it's
not that complicated really is to say
well I just want a part of this function
I just want a part of it such that it
will pass the horizontal line test okay
now when you have a look at this and I
took it off the screen but it's
different with all those other functions
I mentioned right why is it that this
function fails the horizontal line test
but none of the others do this simple
function has a particular feature that
makes it break this rule what feature is
it it has a tooth point right there that
guy there is the problem because as soon
as you turn you're going to come back
and it means it's going to overlap
you're getting that second part right
and your horizontal line test fails so
therefore it's going to be either side
of this turning point okay so here's
what I'm going to say we can restrict
the domain
we can restrict the date domain of a
function that fails the horizontal line
test in order to get pot that passes it
and they begin to invest function out of
that so we can restrict the domain of
any function by paying attention to the
stationary points I should have said the
turning points
okay so because I've got two sides of y
equals x squared I can equally say I can
take the left hand side
that'll give me an inverse function or I
can take the right hand side that will
also give me an investment why is it
that we chose the right hand side it's
back
I drew a shape yesterday that helps you
I can choose either side what was that
one
kind of negative square roots what I'm
choosing between is these two not these
two right yeah so I think these are okay
they're real numbers I'm happy with them
they're not equally nice but why not the
equally nice why do I want these guys
and not the others
what problem I try to solve I'm trying
to find a length aside right which has
to be positive okay so if like the main
use case that you're using this function
for is to find positive things
why not restrict the original function
such that you only get positive values
back right so in this case we can say FX
equals x squared has no inverse function
but f of x equals x squared in the
domain X is greater than equals y this
guy has an inverse function and we
define a we call it the square root of x
okay so you know when you go back all
the way back to when you first learn
what these things are and they said yeah
but why can't you know if I say X equals
the square root of 25 why can't it be
plus or minus five and the reason why is
because we define it this way because it
makes so much more sense to us it's so
much more useful if we say just get one
number out of there okay make it
function model relation so let's just
review what have we said we know what an
inverse E is geometrically algebraically
we know how to write it down we know how
to go from a function to its inverse go
from the domain and range of 1 to the
domain range of the other and how to
make sure you can test did I get the
right inverse did I calculate the right
thing you should be able to combine them
and you shouldn't return back to your
original input okay and lastly we have
this idea which really is very important
to us with trig functions so just have a
think about it for wine is really
important for restricting the domain
that will give you an inverse function
otherwise you've got stopped right you
won't get an infection out of it